ah ah ah
[music]
noooooo
me
ni
oh am
uso
n ame
ni
me
[music]
this is a fresh ale and over there is a human
area, isn't this area a bit of a god edia
2 here  By coming, I can say that I am a
cure or a god
at the entrance
.
[Music] In the
olden days, it was Sarugaku.
[music]
me
[music] When the
audience sees the relative
without a mask,
they feel that the expression on the person's face is visible.
You
can't go deep with a mask
[music] [music] [music] [music]
hey
[music]
Muromachi period When sarugaku was developing, it was
a small group of sarugaku  In that group, there was
no main thing that people would say, so
I thought for myself which mask would be suitable for the song
I composed
.  Music]
Right now
I'm the only one
[Music]
The reason for that is, of course, that I'm performing myself,
so I really need to change this expression
.
There is no rehearsal for Shinonome this time, so it's going to be the actual performance right away.
And
finally, in the Hong Kong version, it seems that the Hong Kong version is still thinking about it on a real stage
.
At the moment when it shines when you do it  There is nature and
it shines A
wonderful freshness also shines
That's
what honto no is beautiful It's
always about once a month I go there without fail, and I
report that Ono has finished successfully, and there will be this stage one after another
[music]
ni
Not only the brain, but also tea flowers,
or even grapes.
How do you think Japan is already a country of robots with only economic laws
?
]
[music]
wool